do
[Music]
do
nice fresh glass of
water
oh i see we have merlot flavored water
in the chat
that's a good choice i approve
hey everybody
hope everyone's doing well
um
don't have a
specific topic to um
to tackle this time if i
did i would have put it in the um
in the title
of the live stream but i don't so it's
whatever comes up it is to water that is
my story and i'm sticking to it and you
can't prove otherwise
unless you're hiding in my house and
secretly sipping my water in which case
all that would do is confirm that it is
in fact water
did i get new glasses i did i knew
glasses frames come in
yesterday i think
um i bought these
so i bought these actually
in a a little bit of potentially
uh silly optimism because i wanted them
to match one of the outfits i'm planning
to wear
at gallifrey one next month assuming it
still happens we will see
uh so
so many folks here hi everybody good to
see you all oh
michael anderson doyle
thank you so much for the membership
dharma the robot girl celebrating their
three-month anniversary all hail queen
nathaniel salute thank you
always happy to have you here
much appreciated how are things things
are okay
um i'm
i'm actually
uh
slightly ahead
of my workload i just need to stay there
because as i mentioned if gallifrey1
does in fact
happen
then um i need to not be behind work so
that i can do that oh hey meg i'm glad
you made it
the lighting yeah i probably could have
fiddled it with it more so it wasn't
quite as uh
dark and moody although people seem to
like it okay but
it was like it was all blown out and i i
adjusted that and i fixed that and i'm
like well heck i'm running late we'll
just go with it um as soon as i sorted
that out
um just watched my first bollywood movie
and it was really good in case you're
curious it's called
uh
baggy
hmm
interesting i haven't heard of that one
well i say that as if i know
as if i know indian film very well i
don't i've really still only seen the
one i was commissioned for several years
ago which was bahubali
which was
great it's
nuts and i liked it quite a bit um
but i i can't i can't pretend i know
much about the industry or the
genres or what have you
because bollywood is not a genre
bollywood is simply indicating where a
film was made
uh is this a different room why the
change no
no same room it's my office it's
where i've been doing like the only
thing that's changed is
months ago i was doing it from
over there that was back when i still
was using the laptop
i was set up in front of my usual
um
shooting space
um but now that i have gotten a new
desktop
that isn't mobile and i can't move the
whole freaking thing over there and if i
want to be able to see the chat and have
the cam and have the webcam and
everything i now do it from the desk
i've
been doing it from here for
a couple of months now so i don't know
if you've missed a lot of it just looks
different because of how dark it is
fingers crossed for gala for one yes
yes we'll see
curious in preparation for the easter
special are you going to watch the john
perry story the sea devils funny i i
that actually occurred to me earlier
today thinking oh
i should do that um it would actually be
a re-watch because while i haven't done
a review on that one because it's been
so long since i've seen it
i have seen the sea devils before it's
actually one of
one of my preferred third doctor stories
at least by memory as i said it's been a
while so i do need to rewatch that and i
should try and do that before that
happens
i got my cos daddy replica of the 12th
doctor's linen coat it rocks oh it does
doesn't it
um cos eddie was also where i got my uh
coat that i used for 12th doctor
it's it's a it's nice i love it
love the earrings thank you
thank you i enjoy these nice sparkly
um i don't think you've learned your
lesson i'm trying to use
uh
a green i don't think i learned to your
lesson i'm trying to use a green screen
in a video
well
[Music]
um assuming you're not suffering from my
degree of adhd hopefully you will take
the time to look up how to adjust and
fine-tune it because the reason my early
green screen sucked so hard was i didn't
really properly know how to use the
software and i didn't realize all the
adjustments that you could make
so like whenever i tried to make
adjustments to have it look better i was
just changing my lighting when i shot it
as opposed to fiddling with the settings
in the damn editing software because i
was a [ __ ]
so that's why the last time i did green
screen which was
the
uh 90s comics retrial for death of
superman
that one the green screen while it's
still very obviously green screen
doesn't look terrible
because i figured out how to actually do
it properly
still pain in the butt to work with
listen to the 2002 tick tick boom
soundtrack my main takeaway damn dr
chilton is a good singer oh is he on
that
who who is he singing what part is he
singing for that
i have a captain jack coat from abby
shot oh
not like i
the priority of getting
jack harkness cosplay has gone down the
list a bit i think missy's still my top
priority but like i
still even now i wouldn't mind the
captain jack coat
um
according to ben i'm the watering police
i would say you're more like the
watering neighborhood watch you carry no
actual authority you just keep reporting
stuff left and right as if it will
actually change anything
uh if i were to do a modern cosplay it'd
be oz good oh that'd be adorable
[Music]
caroline
i'm not like
make your own decision on whether or not
you're comfortable but like i support it
um
mr will guitar thank you so much for the
super chat you get a heart
thank you for all your reviews and work
always insightful and interesting much
appreciated many many thanks oh thank
you
thank you very much i appreciate that i
i do my best it is it
it continues to be like oddly
um surprising to me that like people
still stick around for
me just cranking out this nonsense
so since you've been playing final
fantasy 7 a remake do you have any
questions because i did it but tons of
research into it so i can hopefully
answer any questions i mean
most of my questions i'm hoping will get
addressed within the story itself so i'm
gonna say no
i have had some people watching me on
stream who like
uh had obviously played the original
more recent so there were times i'm like
i don't remember this and they'd be like
no that was in the original be like oh
okay sorry
um i have started getting better about
looking that up like
the point i'm at in the game scarlett
just showed up and i was like i think i
remember her and i look at him like oh
right like once i saw her polygon
uh her old
massive blocky polygon version i'm like
oh right her because like in the remake
she is just
she is so mommy dom
it's
ridiculous and i never
that never came across strongly enough
with the boxy chunky pixels and and no
voice so you know sometimes i don't
always connect the dots
uh raul espenza played jonathan okay
i have the cause daddy john sim master
coat from the dr falls that's also a
good coat that's on my wish list
uh
is batman 2 hours and 55 minutes too
long
i cannot say that definitively
until i have seen the film
because
i do have to um
be prepared for the possibility that the
story it's telling and the way that it's
telling it does justify that run time
that having been said my god instinct is
yes yes that is
too damn long
apparently the rough cut was four hours
which in and of itself is not super
uncommon
rough cuts are always longer
but
there's reports coming out that
um warner brothers was seriously
considering releasing it as a four hour
cut and just
like here's here's the thing with the
movie that long
especially
when it's something that
the world in general knows
uh already like it's an established
thing like batman people get the core of
batman so there's actually a bunch of
stuff that you don't have to explain
like you don't have to cover a ton of
the nuts and bolts i mean it could but
like that would almost feel like a waste
of time so like when you tell me there's
a batman movie that's almost three hours
long my gut instinct to that is okay
they either made two movies and crammed
it into one or they made what should
have been a season's worth of television
and crammed it into a movie and neither
of those possibilities
is very appealing to me again it's not
impossible
long movies can work but
i just missed the days when 90 to 100
minutes was the standard and two hours
was considered a long or long-ish movie
where as opposed to now where like
almost nothing is under two hours
anymore and
i kind of miss the
tightness i like
i like things tight
i don't need everything to be tight i
can i can have fun with something that's
um
a little looser um or even quite a bit
looser that if if it is
presented well but i'm just saying we
don't have a lot of tightness right now
that you would look so beautiful dress
up like missy ah
thank you
um knitting crochet tiger i i do want to
get
um
a uh a missy cosplay pulled together at
some point
you wouldn't believe who's rumored to be
the 14th doctor i know who's rumored to
be the 14th
really sick of hearing that brought up
my friend and i had a stressful day so
to relax we watched ms mojo videos of
glee
while consuming junk food and soft
drinks and making snarky comments
i mean however you unwind
uh have i watched the new season of
cobra kai nope
nope i have um
i i don't have a lot of motivation i
really
i didn't love season three when i
watched it and as time went on i was
like i really didn't like season three
that doesn't automatically mean season
four will be bad it just kind of killed
my motivation to barrel through it when
i've got other stuff i could be doing um
i'm kind of prior and like also that's a
show that liz and i um
watch together
so
um and like i'm kind of prioritizing
getting her to watch arcane over us
doing
um
cobra kai first we have to finish up the
sixth season of uh legends of tomorrow
which we're almost done with i think
we're down to the last three episodes or
so
that's just so stupid i love it it's so
dumb
my success depends on having
adhd's sake
yeah um
i'm not saying you can't be successful
with adhd i'm just saying it's um
it's something you're gonna be working
around
for
ever
uh am i a fan of uh args no
i am
super super naught
have never been like i remember when
args were used as promotional material
like way back when the freaking dark
knight came out and i was bored by the
idea then like
people had to like all these people
online like went around to find like
snapshot these things that were in the
real world and like put all these bits
of data together to put together a
promotional image i think it was the
joker i can't remember i remember
thinking like i looked up the results on
what people went through to get it done
and i'm like oh well it's impressive
that they did it i never want to
participate in that and like i know
that's not exactly what args are anymore
but like the entire concept of them like
no interest
zero none
uh
if tenant is the next doctor what were
your thoughts beyond that see i notice
you're wording that very carefully
because i've gone on a record multiple
places saying i have no opinion until
it's confirmed and so you're wording
your question as well if it was
confirmed then what would your opinion
be sneaky nice try not answering it
look
it would be a bad idea
i am actually you know what screw it
let's let's dig into this uh a little
bit
the idea of bringing back david tennant
to play the doctor again is a bad idea
it is a fundamentally bad idea and
before anyone shows up in the comments
telling me oh well the curator said you
could he could revisit old faces like i
know that it's not a question of they
can't do it because of xyz it's all made
up they can come up with a narrative
justification for why they should do it
that doesn't make it a good idea and uh
the other thing i've seen people go like
oh well he's not going to be playing the
tenth doctor again it's going to be
david tennant reinterpreting the doctors
who would be a different doctor not just
doing his old version like yeah sounds
good still a bad idea this kind of
cyclical recursive
masturbatory nonsense i just i'm
knocking stuff over
this is what i dread for doctor who this
is the exact reason why i don't want
russell t davies to spend any time
retconing the timeless child as much as
i hate it because stop looking back move
forward and i don't care if he'd be
playing a different version of the
doctor casting tenant to play the doctor
again is a retrograde move it is looking
back instead of trying to progress and
whatever you feel about chibnall's time
and i have not liked most of it
he
did try and move things forward did it
work no but it is healthier for this
show and for its future to find a way to
move forward than to start looking back
and just jerking off its own freaking
continuity
fan service wankery the whole idea
be a terrible notion and i've seen a
million things like oh well you'd only
do one series oh it would just be a
couple of specials and that'll be it's a
bad idea
i don't care how you package it i don't
care what you wrap it in fundamentally
it is a bad idea and it is unhealthy for
the state of the franchise
don't do it
and don't tell me any reasons why you
think i should be more optimistic about
the idea i'm not
it is the kind of thing i dread
doctor who doing
and i have for a long time
nosferatu turns a hundred
just shift tone let's forgot to turn
foreign march have i seen shadow of the
vampire i have i remember wishing i
liked it more than i did
uh i think if davis comes back it will
just damage the show
i don't see uh oh no david oh so you are
talking to
david tennant for some reason my brain
read that it's davies as in russell t
okay that's fine
spank is not a naughty word miss wicked
wolf
it's it's a word like any other the
action can be naughty or can at least be
applied to people who have been
just saying
just to sway you towards cobra kai they
fully explained terry silver's actions
in the karate kid 3 and it makes so much
sense i don't want his actions explained
he was a [ __ ] character
he was a i didn't like why
why do you think it's a selling point
that they justify the existence of a
character i don't like
that this
feels like the whole
um friggin
jar jar [ __ ] sith lord thing it's like
even if any of that was true it wouldn't
make me suddenly like the character i
don't like him
i'm very exasperated this stream
i hope people are getting entertainment
out of that
i was just came in on the 60th oh i
fully expect him to show up in the 60th
um
that i that i don't doubt and would not
have a problem with i'm fine with
multi-doctor stories
but like that's not what people are
talking about
um
my opinion on marvel what if is not
marvel what if it's mcu what if which in
my opinion severely limits their
creativity and weirdness that what if
stories are known for well i mean like
it was gonna have to be mcu what if
because
that's what people know because if you
did
a com like what ifing off of um
the
the the comics then
there's your whole chunk of your
audience isn't even gonna know what
you're ripping what you're riffing off
of so
like i i will absolutely grant you that
it was far more restrained and far less
bizarre than i would have liked
for um
for what if to be
but like it was always going to be mcu
what if that's
that's what's
there that's that's what it was always
going to be uh strom dynasty you had
sent a super chat earlier when when do i
think we'll know the next doctor if i
were to guess
uh between the airings of the upcoming
special uh for easter and whenever the
next special after that is that would be
my guess
um assuming they can keep a lid on it
that's always the issue is avoiding
leaks
and jack jordan thank you very much for
the super chat
how could the doctor be portrayed
if they were trans
see the interesting
thing about the doctor is
it it would be
it would be
an odd thing to do the doctor as a trans
character
simply because there's already the
potential for
just using um
regeneration
as a trans
allegory in and of itself
and
there's still a lot of nebulousness over
how much the doctor does or doesn't
control the body that they get so the
idea of a doctor being trans
um leans into the idea that there is
virtually no control which isn't
contradicting cannon really um
but
it i don't know something about that
would feel what i would like to see i
would like to see a non-binary doctor
who's just referred to as they
and that's it
like not a big deal made out of it that
would kind of be i i personally would
actually prefer that to seeing them
trying to do an actual trans narrative
with the doctor
um partially because i don't know if i
trust the show to do it well
given the current topic you might as
well check the discord now oh okay
so i guess i'm checking the discord
early
feel free to decide if this is too
potentially spoilery but the david
tennant coming back is the 14th doctor
rumors flying right now there's nothing
to indicate we should be taking those
seriously is there honestly as much as
i'd love david at 10 i hope they don't
go there no there is absolutely nothing
to indicate there are people who are
claiming oh the leak source has been
right about other stuff without actually
providing information as to who the leak
source is or you know it
it's
it's it's a game of telephone
like it could be anything
from
he is going to appear in the 60th
anniversary and that has been twisted by
you know it by being leaked in a in a
slightly off form
uh it could be that
um
or it could just have been pulled out of
the ether from fans who saw that um
russell t davis was coming back and
they're like oh maybe tenant and then
they start talking about as if it
actually will because the conversation
can shift from oh well maybe this would
be hap maybe this would happen to
wouldn't it be cool if this happened too
i bet this will happen to this is
happening like it's a it's a standard
like self-creating rumor mill
progression
following on from the above question if
um we're i'm right now i'm dealing with
questions on the discord so i'll be back
in the main chat in a minute
discord is a perk to the council of
geeks patreon page so you can support me
there and get access to the discord just
saying
uh if god forbid someone made the stupid
decision to bring back a previous actor
for a different regeneration who would
you rather they chose i.e who do you
think could best distance themselves
from their original run rather than
retreading
old ground um
see the thing is you're basically asking
me to say who the who the
actor with the biggest range is
and i don't
know if i have an answer for that
because honestly based off what i've
seen
it might be jodie whittaker
but
obviously that's not going to happen
because she's the outgoing
um
so
logistically that wouldn't make sense
for the purposes of your question
um
don't know
like it's not an uninteresting question
but
it's it's also unfortunately the kind of
uh what if scenario that like my head is
just really bad at
processing uh it's the same reason i'm
bad at fan casting like i just can't
i can't get my head
into the space where the question
makes anything more than just logistical
sense to me like i understand what
you're asking
but my brain doesn't work that way
um i'd say him again purely for the
reason that fewer people will have seen
his contributions well that's
like
that means that it's avoiding retreading
old old ground only for anyone who
doesn't listen to big finish i mean he's
effectively been playing the doctor
continuously for almost 20 years in
audio form so i don't know
uh since
man this this really did become the
topic of the discord since tenant being
cast as the next doctor is unlikely and
a bad idea thank you uh what would you
think of him reprising his role as 10
throughout a future season i.e
not just for an anniversary special for
some tiny whiny shenanigans alongside
whichever new doctor we get or any other
previous doctors no i do not think any
doctor especially a fan favorite like
tenant
uh should be brought back on anything
other than a one-off basis um weaving
him throughout a future season is just
going to beg the comparison to whoever
the current doctor is and ignite all the
more divides about why why won't you
just give us another series with tenant
if you're going to have more the one
exception i'll make is
i i'm shocked this has not happened
uh already
i would be okay
if they wanted to bring in
the metacrisis doctor
that uh
is living with rose in the parallel
dimension now when i say bring in i
don't mean take over the role of the
doctor i don't mean that at all but i
mean given that he is human that he has
been earthbound and that it is now oh
god like 15 years later or whatever
seeing how he's changed seeing how he's
different see it's funny the reason i
say it's funny that this hasn't happened
yet is
i kind of made the ins the assumption
that half the reason to even create that
situation where there was a completely
separate doctor who it's established
formerly would age would be able to
bring david tennant back
at a later date and not worry about
having to cover for the fact that he is
visibly older
um which is an issue that wasn't so much
of a problem in multi-doctor stories
back in the classic era because the
definition was so low but these days it
shows you can tell honestly you could
kind of tell in the day of the doctor he
looked older
again that's not like he's aging quite
well but
i always kind of assumed that was the
point of creating the metacrisis doctor
to be able to do that
and they still haven't so
i'd be up for that i don't want it to
dominate like a season-long story but if
i don't know
for a finale or one-off or a special if
they wanted to touch on that that's
probably what i'd be most okay with in
terms of the idea of bringing him back
for anything other than like the 60th
anniversary
thoughts on the scream movies also i
highly recommend watching cobra kai uh
for terry dudes terrifying
um
uh i have only seen the first three
screen movies i haven't seen screen four
i haven't seen the newest one
uh the first one
was really clever when it came out
spawned a legion of imitators including
its own damn sequels i've heard that
scream 4 is decent i've heard the latest
scream is actually quite good but i
haven't seen them so
they with those first three they got a
little bit worse with each entry
okay i am now going to pop over
to the chat again
cool thank you for your patience
everybody i'm sure there is a ton of
conversation i have missed in the
interim so apologies for that i'm not
going to try and catch up i'm just going
to pick up with where the chat is right
now
hearing all of this here's an odd
question
when do you think fan service is done
well in anything in general i think
generally fan service is best done in a
minimal context
for me
the best kind of fan service
is something that
fans will spot
but people who don't recognize the
significance of it to the history uh you
know and don't have the fandom response
to it
they won't it won't be made obvious to
them that they're missing something it's
it's something where
the knowledge of like oh i know what
that is and like what it means and where
it might be going
is a pop for those who recognize it but
the trick is presenting it in a way that
doesn't leave people who don't recognize
it going well clearly you're referencing
something i don't know so now i'm lost
it's a fine balance to make and i always
encourage a light
touch on these things that is generally
what i think is the best way to handle
fan service
exams have been exhausting i wanted to
say hi but i should get going great to
see you there you look amazing as ever
thank you cora
question in final fantasy 7 remake uh
how far have you uh gotten like
uh have climbed up the stairs i have not
climbed the stairs yet no we only um we
only just blew up the second mako
reactor
um i've uh
and cloud is currently with
aerith uh we have not rejoined the rest
of the group yet that's where i'm at
with that
if they're filming secret invasion in my
town right now you're a skrull aren't
you
the actress who plays tori and cobra kai
is the lead in a slasher film called
eileen warno's american boogie woman oh
no
oh
no
oh wait is that from that same
freaking guy hang on a second
there's this guy who's like made a niche
for himself
um
directing these
terrible
um
like weird alternate takes on
real life um
oh yeah it's him
ah
daniel faran's ugh
oh
dude's gross like i don't know what he's
like as a human being but his movie
projects from the last
couple years they are fundamentally
disgusting
to me he did one on sharon tate one on
nicole
brown simpson
and now ted bundy and eileen warno's
that ah i don't know who's giving that
guy money they need to stop he does
these weird
alternate history versions of real life
killers with
no respect for the actual people and
victims involved it's it's gross what he
does creatively is gross
have i played never have i ever yeah
i went to college
i don't want them to do this but i would
kind of respect if they announced david
10 as the new doctor but didn't make new
episodes just aired his old ones
i wouldn't even respect that because
that's just jerking people around i have
no respect for that
i have zero zero respect for that on
principle
first screen movie is based on a murder
that happened in northern louisiana i
did not know that
huh
or if i did know that i don't know that
that's tickling like a little bit of
familiarity fit familiar for me fat food
familiarity in the back of my head so
maybe i did know that
i don't know
it's funny with one miss click you can
be talking about peter davison but
accidentally type pete davis and
yeah no that's ooh boy that's that's a
that's a that's a harsh turn right there
uh
ma
captain omni thank you so much a heart
for you for the super chat matter eater
lag can bite through anything and eat
anything he's my favorite lethal joke
character what's what's your favorite
um
i don't know i will say this the the
matter eater lad um references in
peacemaker
were very funny and i did enjoy those
both references to both his power
that it's kind of terrifying
the absurdity of it and also the
silliness of the name like they covered
a lot of ground in just a few bits of
dialogue
i enjoyed that a lot um
lethal joke characters um
i don't know
ah
i have to think about that
i have i don't oh geez
that's a great question that i wish i
had an answer to if i think of an answer
um
i i will tell you i i don't i can't
promise i will though
um
still not clear what's wrong with what
he does okay well okay so
uh uh black cover without getting into
like super because i don't want to i
don't want to give this freaking guy
oxygen
he
it's not even that he alters details of
actual murders to turn them into
something that better resembles a
um
you know a standard hollywood script
which also isn't great but like that's
not what he does he does these
full
conspiratorial twistings and
absolutely disrespects people both alive
and dead
um
with no regard for the actual history of
what happened often introducing just
absolute nonsense elements including
like supernatural elements to people
like to people who are dead who are
really dead
and it's it's just it's gross it's it's
really gross
do i think the riddler becoming an edgy
nolan s villain in batman is a bad move
he's not even nolanesque he's
fincher-esque
he's freaking john doe from seven yes i
think it's a bad move i don't like it
so i kind of stopped watching mcu movies
after infinity war because the film
after it was captain marvel i don't much
care for captain marvel so how important
is cm can i skip it um as a film yes you
can
i mean understand captain marvel is
going to show up when you get to uh end
game
um but
like if you know who she is you don't
need to have known the specifics of what
happened in her movie so yeah
if you wanted to skip it you can skip it
and the movies that follow will make
sense
um i don't they're it's possible that
things like
secret invasion coming up on disney plus
that might not make sense um because a
lot of skrull stuff goes on in the
captain marvel movie but we won't know
until that comes out
um
daniel friends made two good movies they
were in-depth documentaries on the elm
street and friday 13th franchises well
like
if if if he was just doing documentaries
on the creation of those there was less
wiggle room for him to
just be
gross
just watch the new season of america
horror story i forget they still have
new seasons coming out on that not gonna
lie first half is my new favorite season
they do a double feature interesting
uh strong dynasty thank you so much for
the super chat much appreciated my ideal
age for dr actor old young i have no
ideal age and for me it comes down to
performance and the reason i don't have
an ideal age
is because
prior to matt smith's casting
when when it was known david tennant was
leaving i desperately wanted an older
doctor and then matt smith showed up and
absolutely blew me away and i loved him
and that kind of that kind of shattered
my
preconceived notions about what a new
doctor would bring versus what an old
doctor would bring it really is going to
come down to the performance
and i don't think
that the
physical age of the actor
is
really all that key
to how i take in
uh performances
that said they should never cast a kid
or a teenager
and that's just because like the the
vibe would be
very
very off going that young like
having somebody that young running
around and
um
you know getting into space laser
battles it is a very different vibe
fundamentally from
you know an adult even a young
adult um
oh john vinyls thank you so much for the
super chat imagine if someone did a
really good film adaptation of the story
story of osiris and isis
i used to know that story better than i
currently do
um
i worry that at this point it's it's
formed into a bit of a
just a mush of
uh egyptian mythology that i have not
parsed in a long time
on the topic of jokers do you think we
uh will get a
live action new 52 joker like the gotham
tv show well okay so it depends on what
you mean by new 52 joker because jerome
um who is probably who you're
referencing um he
gave
visual reference to the new 52 joker but
he was not
i don't like the new 52 joker
very much
i don't like
a lot of the core conceptions behind him
nor do i particularly care for how
excessively
[Music]
cruelly nihilistically
gorilly vicious he was
it felt like it was all done for shock
factor
um but i do like jerome on gotham so i
don't feel that jerome from gotham is
the new 52 joker in terms of overall
personality certainly not in terms of
some of the um
very stupid specifics they chose to do
with
the joke who
whoever's idea it was
to make the joker effectively immortal
and give him a healing factor
and i don't know if that ever eventually
got rolled back but i know was the case
for a while
they are very very very very very very
stupid and should not have been allowed
to have that kind of creative input
that was a very stupid idea because part
of the core the part of not the only but
part of the reason that the joker is the
ideal villain for batman is that batman
when done right represents the best that
a human being can be
the best physical condition the best
mental acuity the most sharp the
putting the most of himself into making
the world a better place as he possibly
can
that is the best of what humanity
without superpowers can attain and a
proper inverse of that being the joker
is that he is the worst
that humanity can be
he is the horrible
nihilistic
just
finds joy in these sickest things
and things that no one should find funny
that's where his joy come comes from
this is the darkest side of humanity but
he needs to be human
he needs to not have superpowers because
that
makes him a proper inverse of batman in
that way in the instant you give him any
kind of superpower
you have diminished and lost that aspect
of him
and to what freaking end well we gotta
explain how he lives through all this
stuff it's comic books
people live through blatantly
unsurvivable things all the time without
having super powers
stop it
on the top oh i read that
scroll down
would you prefer dumb dumbo or bambi i
don't know i haven't rewatched either in
a long time don't really want to it's
gonna be uh an aristocats live-action
remake what are your thoughts waste of
time wasted money won't see it never
mind dr
uh never mind david 10 is the 14th
doctor david tennant is the riddler i
remember that being a bit of fan casting
um
after
dark knight i remember seeing um
fan made mock-up posters with him as the
riddler so like that's not even a new
idea
thoughts on the flash movie erasing the
entire dcu personally i like the idea
but wb just making random things that
are loosely connected uh with only a few
bits of dialogue see like we don't
really know
if that's what it's doing
i wouldn't be surprised if it's a bit
more of a
messy multiverse situation basically
establishing that
establishing don't worry about
continuity if something doesn't fit it's
an alternate version
as opposed to actively erasing what came
before which honestly at this point
especially given the given you know the
opinions of um snyder's justice league
and whatnot i also think would be kind
of a dick move like
if if you want to establish that the
primary continuity we're gonna follow
going forward isn't that one that's one
thing but actually erasing it like
pulling a crisis on infinite earths and
wiping it out
would just kind of be a dick move let
people think let people who like it
think oh well they're going to continue
off in their own thing and have their
own adventures we won't see them anymore
and that bums me out but at least
they're still around like goodwill
there's no reason not to do that
[Music]
how do i feel about joe martin's 14 do
it do it do it did a whole video on why
they should do it do it
uh
captain omni once again thank you for
the super chat
ignore captain marvel embrace shazam
he's the original captain marvel has
deeper mythos and ton more villains such
as the monster society of evil
um i keep forgetting that shazam is
getting a sequel um
that movie was uh
[Music]
that that movie was
fine
and fun i enjoyed it
um but it didn't blow me away i know i
have some friends who really really
really liked it though
but yes
shazam was the original captain marvel
that's copyright nonsense for you
like the whole thing with shazam is
weird because he was he was he he was
created by charlton comics
actually became more popular than
superman
tron comics
was taken to court by dc for decades
basically until charlton started losing
money and their comics weren't
profitable anymore and they just gave up
fighting the copyright issues
from dc claiming that
uh captain what who was known at the
time captain marvel was just a rip-off
of superman which
like the gimmick's different but
they're not completely wrong about that
at least
conceptually um
so
you know and then and then dc ends up
owning
captain marvel but then the rights to
the name specifically laps so marvel
snaps it up and then for a long time
like he was still called captain marvel
at dc but they just couldn't put that on
the covers on the covers it had to be
the power shazam and eventually they
just gave up even having the dual thing
he just called the character shazam like
it's it's been a weird trip with all
that
uh what classic who
cereals would you turn into a movie like
the cushing movies my pick would be the
third doctor or one let the man go full
bond
um
again it's not something that i've ever
considered and i'm not sure i can get
um
[Music]
i i i'm not sure i can get my head
wrapped around the idea
well enough to actually
have an answer
i don't know
[Laughter]
i i'd have to think about it i mean like
third doctor stories would adapt well to
film specifically because they are more
action oriented in film especially these
days kind of needs to be
so maybe
uh you know the idiots lantern and the
crimson horror were both written by mark
gadis i'm aware
i just thought maybe
aydah not forgiving her mother at the
end uh was a lot more deliberate
possibly but that doesn't make up for
the fact that idiot lantern still exists
and still has the message it does
if
mark gadis
made the deliberate choice and i don't
know that he did but if at a later point
he made the deliberate choice to do the
opposite of the very screwed up thing
that he did in the idiot's lantern
then that would improve my opinion of
him
as a writer
recognizing and correcting for issues
he'd had it does nothing about my
opinion of the idiot's lantern that
episode can burn in hell
i already know the scrolls from avengers
earth mightiest heroes so how different
are the mcu scrolls also i don't care
about spoilers it's not that the scrolls
are different it's that
it's setting up exactly sort of what
their status quo is because they are
they are not uh at least as presented in
captain marvel they are not active
aggressors they are refugees they are
fleeing from the cree
um
so that's sort of the main thing they
have got going on right now
thanks for the response happy to respond
um
[Music]
captain omni once again thank you
fawcett comics was captain rebel ah
shoot that's right
oh i knew that too because because like
when they
ported it over to dc they had him
originate in fawcett city in one version
i knew that
ah nuts yeah charlton was peacemaker
question blue beetle nightshade captain
adam yeah yep you're right dang it
ah
i knew that too
i did know that i still got it wrong
too many names to keep straight
why do i hate the idiots lantern for
trying to forgive the abusive father but
like it takes you away which does the
same thing well
two major differences firstly
um i haven't praised that specific
aspect of it takes you away and one
thing that i will not about idiots
lantern is it's not just that i find
that message revolting is that it's a
really really
really bad
episode
in and of itself
already
um so it was already bad and then did
that if it was a matter of it was a good
episode that did that i still wouldn't
like it but it wouldn't piss me off
quite to the degree of rage that i have
for idiots lantern because it's already
bad it is a bad story with a bad villain
badly told
and then it does that at the end and it
just i'm already wound up because i
don't like it
so
that that was always gonna hit me much
harder now keep in mind i have not
re-watched it takes you away so i'm
working off slightly faded memories and
it's distinctly possible that when i get
to a re-watch i will assess that
somewhat differently but to my memory at
least
the issues with the father there were
not the same can of worms it was neglect
as opposed to active abuse now that is
not me saying neglect is okay
it's not
but there is a difference between
neglect and active abuse especially when
there is an outside force contributing
to the situation that was going on
between that guy and his daughter again
that's me working off memories so don't
don't sh don't turn this into a thing
where you correct me with fine details
i'm sure i'll address it when i
eventually re-watch the thing
but the idiot's lantern
the man is actively abusive
regardless
of
the supernatural alien stuff going on so
there you can't even make an argument of
something tipped the scale something
twisted his brain he was just a twisted
human being
and i think comparing that to a guy who
was in an extraordinary situation
and may have had his mind frankly
directly twisted as we kind of saw it
impacting grant or starting to impact
graham in a similar way comparing that
to somebody who was just a fundamentally
consciously deliberately and repeatedly
terrible human being with no
intervention on anybody else's part
no
no that is no those are not equivocal
uh
do you do i think they should bring back
the amalgam universe
no
but
i would kind of like to see like
animated adaptations of the amalgam
universe because that
the funniest thing to me about that
wasn't that it is not that it wasn't
that it existed i could talk
it's that it had continuity
like it was such it was so
it was such a stupid gimmick and it had
continuity
if people don't know what i'm talking
about the amalgam universe was a thing
that dc and marvel did where they
literally would take their most popular
characters and mash them together
and so there was a universe of all these
hybrid characters like um
they mashed together wolverine and
batman to make dark claw and i think
they matched together like elektra and
catwoman i don't even remember all of
these like there was a lot of them but
it was ongoing for a while and it had
continuity it was the stupidest thing in
the best way
like that
a lot of 90s entertainment particularly
90s comics are dumb in an infuriating
way but that's the good kind of 90s dumb
that is the kind of dumb that is
enjoyable and would not have happened at
any other time and because of the 90s
dark and grim grittiness it took itself
way more seriously than it should have
which again just makes it funnier
why i love the joker as a villain is
because he's such a showman and has made
such an impact on gotham that the person
of the joker may die in the idea of the
joker wollander for eons well that was
kind of like at the heart of a lot of
what gotham did with the idea of him
um
but like yeah for me i'm kind of with
you on the showman thing and that's
something that
i feel like when the focus becomes on
how
twisted and
just gruesome
his crimes are it loses sight of the
showmanship because there are ways to be
showy other than just being
jigsaw
you know for all intents and purposes
so
i
my preferred version of
the
uh of the joker is someone who is always
trying to make as big a show and as big
a splash as possible
and sometimes that means gutting people
sometimes it means
um
having a giant float with his head on it
uh injected into the middle of a parade
like whatever what's gonna make the
biggest show it's not always something
that's gonna get people killed he just
doesn't care if people get killed that's
sort of my preferred overall take on the
joker
like has a general guiding philosophy
showmanship first
consequences don't matter is it going to
make a big show great let's do it
oh batman
you really should have a better idea of
what to expect from me
surprisingly enough macaulay culkin is
quite good in american horror story i
don't find that that surprising i'm not
shocked that when he still chooses to
act which is not often that he's
he's pretty decent
the only egyptian mythology fact i know
is that horus tricked uh sutek into
eating some of his own sexual bodily
fluid
which makes pyramids of mars much
funnier in hindsight
i've been watching avatar the last
airbender i've noticed a lot of woke
things people complain about in shows or
movies today am i a bad person
no but the current conversation and ways
that people talk about things that
honestly are just storytelling tools and
choices
um has seeped into you watching even
things that kind of predate that
specific language that doesn't make you
a bad person
but just kind of be aware of
how these perspectives
shape the viewing experience for you
just try and keep on top of that
i loved your series ranking my favorite
is series two i'll admit tenant
nostalgia plays a part in that
but i actually like all the episodes
idiots lantern and i have stockholm
syndrome
i mean
that's i suppose that's a
that's a uh a reason i can't get too
on your butt about
uh yes yeah so uh uh jason asked about
cobra kai season four
meg kind of already answered you know uh
on this but like i'm not gonna say i'm
avoiding it unless i'm commissioned for
it i'm just saying that like
it's far enough down the priority list
that it's gonna be a little while
i'm not gonna say never but like again
keep in mind that it's a show me and liz
watch together
like
once we finish off and catch up on
legends of tomorrow and then maybe after
arcane
i
maybe we'll try starting it
or maybe we'll um
maybe we'll
get back to sense8 and find a reason to
kick it down the priority list again and
probably by that point um stranger
things season four will be out like that
that's that's the thing i like
i could see it becoming a thing that
just
rather than me saying never gonna watch
that it just sits on the low priority
list and other stuff keeps coming up
ahead of it
captain omni once again thank you
thank you very much
um
joe quesada is the actual reason no more
dc comics crossover in comics kurt
bousiak who did jelly avengers confirmed
quesada burned that bridge hard i'm not
i'm not shocked to hear that quesada's a
bit of a mixed figure oh
michael anderson doyle dharma i missed
uh one of your super chats earlier i
apologize for that um i feel that
unbreakable is one of the best non-comic
book comic book movies made and same
goes for split and glass this is a hill
i will defend
um
i like unbreakable i like split with the
asterisks on that that it
dips into a lot of
very
long-running and
harmful tropes around depictions of
mental illness like i i will absolutely
cop to that anyone who wants to
criticize it on that basis i will not
defend it i do still like it as a movie
glass wasn't great but it was better
than a lot of people gave it credit for
and i did at least find it interesting
um
but not is the one i would feel the
least like defending
uh
peter dinklage for the next doctor well
he's not from the uk so he's
he's out on that basis as far as i'm
concerned
bbc sherlock had a great joker and
moriarty i said what i said
fair enough
uh are you drinking mushed grape
flavored water if so what brand uh no
actually i i am drinking
uh mushed apple flavored water
ah fun fact about me i'm a big mythology
buff the first exposure to mythology
uh as a whole was no joke yu-gi-oh
with an egyptian mythology
hey we've always got uh we've all got
our um
first hands favorite sonic screwdriver
no answer because um eventually ranking
the sonic screwdrivers is on the
eventual to-do list that i still haven't
gotten to so
i don't know
um
i i i see we have a little simply for
peter dinklage going on in the chat
i support it
a very specific question what sound
should a tardis door make
like a
door
like when you say a target story do you
mean the tardis stars and the doctors
artists because that should just sound
like wood on wood
but if you're asking about any other
tardis i
depends on what it's chameleon circuit
has it disguised as i suppose
i like a squeaky hinge
for the tardis
uh they're remaking the honda mansion
starting with keith stanfield and
tiffany haddash what are your thoughts i
knew that that was happening i'm very
i really don't think it's a
it's an attraction that's going to lend
itself to a decent
movie i mean i suppose you could say
that was true of um
pirates of the caribbean as well but at
least pirates
lend themselves to the kind of movie
that disney is willing to make if you're
going to
if you're going to take the kind of
story that haunted mansion the premise
and the concept of it would lead you to
do and you're not gonna lead in lean
into the campiness which is what the
previous adaptation did then
then you're just gonna make a horror
movie i don't see disney making a legit
horror movie out of one of its
family properties so like i don't know
what the point is
i saw belfast today probably going to be
this year's best picture winner
i feel like i've heard of that
i don't know though
beer keep an eye on the clock oh yes
thank you carowind i should try and wrap
up i do have some more stuff i need to
get done tonight so i don't want to
stick too long john vinyls thank you so
very much for the super chat
uh cyrus was murdered by his brother sue
tech who usurped his throne meanwhile
cyrus's wife restored her husband's body
allowing him to posthumously conceive
their son horus
i have questions that i don't have time
to ask
shyamalan has had negative portrayals of
mental illness in all four of his most
recent films
like that's probably true i haven't seen
a lot of his most recent stuff but
um like
these are long-running tropes that
hollywood has had issues with for a very
very very long time and i'm not going to
say that lets him off the hook but i'm
not going to presume um
malice on his part at this point without
having seen any of them strictly because
this is an issue with the entire
industry
um have i watched you on netflix i
haven't liz watches that that is one of
her trash shows
so she enjoys it and enjoys telling me
about it
time to bring back suetec hey why not
uh what's a hill i'm willing to die on
i don't know
there aren't many honestly like as as
worked up as i get
on things
when i ask myself is this a hill i'm
willing to die on
generally if it's anything other than
things like
um
sex workers work trans rights or human
rights
um
bodily autonomy and right to an abortion
is a fundamental right um or it should
be and things like that like
for the kinds of stuff i talk about you
know pop culture stuff i'm not gonna die
on any of these hills
i have my feelings i get very passionate
but
ultimately when i when i ask myself that
question what hell am i prepared to die
on this hill the answer is almost always
no
um i'd like as worked up as i can get
i'm not um
i'm not confrontational by nature
i had a dream the masculine version of
you and the current version of you had a
battle to the death over control of
council of geeks oh he'd get his ass
kicked
did you hear there was originally going
to be i'm just trying to catch up on the
chat did you hear there's originally
going to be a justice league film that
would have released around the same time
as i believe the dark knight called
justice league mortal yeah um george
miller was gonna direct that yeah i know
i'm well aware
um i think army hammer
was gonna be either superman or batman i
forget which
i guess we dodged a bullet there
they did a game of thrones calendar and
put the picture of dinklage on the
shortest month
i shouldn't laugh at that
but i i i couldn't help it
do i think the dune sequel should be
made into the movies i don't know
because i haven't read any of them so i
don't really have an opinion on that
okay big question time who'd win in an
olympic style event underdog or snoopy
who'd win the character with literal
superpowers or the beagle
what
ah
after seeing flux do you think doctor
who will delve more into alternate
realities i hope not
uh isis did what you were thinking and
she used a prosthetic too
i love it
thought some bad knobs and broomsticks
i'm nostalgic for it it's probably not
very good though i haven't rewatched it
in a long time disney did make a horror
movie it's called something wicked this
way comes yeah in 1982
like modern disney's not gonna do that
they did it back when they were throwing
everything at the wall because
everything except for their um
theme parks was losing money
haven't watched hawkeye yet is it worth
it i enjoyed it
um okay oh new type jb lee one last this
is it this is the last thing i'm
addressing is this super chat
uh thank you so much
in the x-men verse i wish there were
more stories on mutants who want to use
their powers on non-superhero work like
medical care labor and education
yeah
like the thing is
when you put the x-men in film
it's hard to do that because they put
the they go for big scale
um
when they do film like that's the kind
of thing that happens in the comics
because you can have those kinds of side
characters as something really long
running and they could do that in a tv
show
but
the size and scope of film kind of means
that that kind of thing doesn't really
happen
um and even if they tried to it would
just be a tiny side character tiny side
plot but anyways
thank you all for joining me i hope you
have a good rest of your day
evening
whatever is left for you have a good
rest of the week
and please remember
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings
and until next time
this council
it's adjourned
oh uh twitch in the morning uh 10 30
twitch.tv slash council of geeks
there we go
[Music]
mckeavy